This video is brought to you by
skillshare.
What's up guys?
Jared again.
Today we're talking about one of the
most nuanced takes on geek culture out
there.
The Big Bang theory.
Yep.
Nope,
not even close.
It's bad.
Like really bad.
In fact,
it's become somewhat of a recurring gag
for us to hate on this show,
so when you sadistic maniacs asked for
what went wrong,
we reached out to one of our unfortunate
writers,
Thomas,
but instead of making this poor bastard
watch all 5,000,
175 minutes of this show,
we just hopped on imdv and grabbed the
top 10 rated episodes.
Sorry,
we cannot afford to pay this man's
therapist,
but I digress.
Why is a show that deals with science,
comics and all that good wise crack
stuff so bad?
Well,
after hours of grueling research,
we suspect it might have something to do
with references,
so it's subtle.
The fate of doctor who's Tardis will be
decided by a game of thrones inspired
death match on the battlefield of
thunder cats versus transformers.
See,
the Big Bang theory isn't just bad.
It's profoundly bad.
It's so bad that it requires philosophy
to understand just how bad it is,
so join me as I attempt to convince you
that the Big Bang theory is proof that
meaning is dead,
woken Louis wise crack addition on the
Big Bang theory,
what went wrong and big.
Shout out to the real MVP,
Thomas for watching this garbage.
The Big Bang theory loves
referentiality.
They referenced cornerstones of nerd
culture like star Trek.
Sheldon's log three,
four,
five point three for Battlestar
Galactica.
That's my original series,
battlestar Galactica flight suit,
and even scientific facts and
mathematical formulas.
They're slipped in to remind us over and
over again that Leonard,
Sheldon,
and company are diehard nerds.
They buy comics,
perform science experiments,
and sometimes described very basic
things like slipping in a bathtub like
this.
Not Surprising.
You have no safety math or adhesive
stickers to allow for purchase on the
surface with a low coefficient of static
friction.
Now,
in case you missed the laugh track,
sheldon giving penny,
the definition of friction was the joke.
You see?
It's funny because it's a reference now.
If you're wondering why you feel a bit
cheated at the punchline here,
it's probably because that definition of
friction was simply slotted in there and
the other scientific statement about the
nature of reality feels like it could
have had the same effect here,
like gravity for instance,
and cue the next job.
I got to go to the emergency room.
Well,
let's say when you're correct,
did you write humorous is no longer
seated in the glenoid socket?
I would certainly think so.
They could have replaced the word
humorous and glenoid socket with
jibberish and most wouldn't know the
difference and that's the problem.
The actual science isn't the job,
but the fact that they're talking about
science is friction isn't funny.
V referenced to friction is funny.
By contrast considered this brief
futurama reference.
For somebody who barely understands math
like me,
the reference will probably evade
detection,
but for those who spot the symbol for
all if know the mathematical symbol for
an infinite sense of countable numbers,
they'll realize that theater is implying
there's an infinite number of screens.
This not only gives an Easter egg for
the mathematically inclined,
but more importantly,
the joke is the impossibilities of a
movie theater having infinite screens.
The joke is about the subject of all,
if no,
not the mere reference to it.
The reference imbues the joke with
additional meaning,
whereas the Big Bang theory accomplishes
the opposite.
Leonard,
do you recall what I said?
I was going to revolutionize humanities
understanding of the Higgs Boson
particle,
and you said,
sheldon,
it's 2:00
AM.
Get Out of my bedroom.
These jokes are at best lazy writing and
at worst,
a small step toward the complete
annihilation of reality.
Yes,
might sound extreme,
but these kinds of references with no
subject is exactly what kept French
philosopher John Beaudry yard up at
night to Baudrillard.
We're living in a state where reality
has been,
oh,
biliterate.
He gives four levels of representation.
The first level is like a picture,
a perfectly accurate representation of
reality.
The second level of representation is
the unfaithful copy.
A filter that makes you look prettier,
thus obscuring your actual face.
Below.
That is the third level of
representation.
One that deliberately hide the fact that
there's no reality being represented
like an artist's rendering of you,
where they've never actually seen you,
and finally the fourth level is reserved
for when signs and representations start
referencing other signs and
representations and all sense of reality
is thrown out the window.
This is when people start photoshopping
a photoshop image or making memes of
other memes in butchery.
Art's eyes were already living in a
world controlled by a system of fourth
order Simulacra or any reference to the
original reality is lost,
which might explain why he technically
considers our reality a simulation.
Now,
if we're being optimistic,
the Big Bang theory is a distorted view
of real nerd culture.
The second order of representation,
it gets a lot of the details wrong,
but it's still about real nerd culture,
but if we're being pessimistic and oh,
we are,
it's a show about nerd culture that has
no relation to reality whatsoever.
Beathard order of representation,
a copy of something that never existed.
It has science without actual science.
It's about nerd culture.
Without real nerds.
They're more like,
what?
Someone who has never met an nerd thinks
they're like,
that's where the bad science references
become relevant to beaudry art more
often than not.
Jokes rely on characters.
Cramming in whatever scientific
explanation is relevant to the action
when our roadways most slippery now.
Okay.
There are three answers,
none of which are correct.
The correct answer is when covered by a
film of liquid sufficient to reduce the
coefficient of static friction between
the tire and the road to essentially
zero,
but not so deep as to introduce a new
source of friction
references for the sake of references.
Jokes that don't rely on any
understanding of the science,
but rather these simple recognition that
this is a scientific reference.
It's the difference between sheldon
explaining how locks work when pennies
locked out.
Damn key out.
It's not surprising that Baldwin lock on
your door uses traditional edge mountain
cylinders.
Whereas the key for your Volkswagen uses
a center cylinder system
and when Leila and the professor are
racing and drama,
Nah,
half a lap,
you forgotten the mobius strip to lapse
is one lap your kids and your topology
in the former.
The joke doesn't rely on an audience
understanding how locks actually work.
The reality is irrelevant as long as we
recognize that sheldon is being
unnecessarily smart.
Whereas in future trauma,
we're laughing at the actual science
referenced in the joke for Beaudry art.
As things progress,
these copies of reality end up becoming
their own reality,
and this is where we see boatyards
dismal vision reflected in the Big Bang
theory.
These copies divorced from reality
either partly or entirely signal,
not only the death of meaning,
but make all ideas interchangeable
because the jokes in the show are
apropos of nothing.
The characters can essentially spew
meaningless nonsense under the guise of
a meaningful job like in the shows game,
mystic warlords of Qa,
which starts as a kind of joke about
magic.
The gathering in visibility,
spelled luminescent,
spell,
and then quickly descends into utter
nonsense to headed tigers.
Three-Headed lion,
sulfur brimstone.
It doesn't matter if they said two
headed tiger,
three-headed lions,
seven headed ethical Logan,
Paul,
or Frankfurt school jamming crusted
Beagle Monster.
The joke will work on the audience no
matter what they say,
because the show functions at a level of
selling you an empty joke under the
guise of a meaningful one.
So here's the big question,
is that if the Big Bang theory's use of
reference for reference's sake,
ultimately points at nothing,
then what are we laughing at?
My hair is growing at the rate of four
point six meters per femtosecond.
Yeah.
Or at least what is the studio audience?
Laughing gas.
It is scientifically impossible for a
person to typical.
Seriously.
Somebody please tell me her new sounded
important,
but what you're forgetting is it was an
achievement in the field of biology
that's all about Yucky squishy thing.
Well,
after conducting a rigorous study,
our team of media experts has come up
with an answer.
The show basically just it's on its
characters.
That's all that's happening.
Princeton fine institution.
They'll place where Albert Einstein
taught and where Leonard got his phd,
so it may have gone downhill
like
when Leonard and Raj think about buying
Howard a prostitute,
following your recent breakup.
She's exactly a stipe a WHO,
if we hired her,
that would cheer him up.
We're not going to get Wolowitz a
hooker.
I'm so lonely and Horny.
I may open this $20 jar of peanuts and
ended.
Okay.
Or like when sheldon defenses girlfriend
Stewart's kind of interested in amy.
Oh,
of course she is.
She's very interesting.
Did you know when she was 14?
She suffered the webbing between her own
toes.
As it turns out,
ripping on people is actually how the
philosophy of humor started in the West.
The earliest theory of humor is the
superiority theory which began with
plato saying that laughter was a form of
scorn that people we laugh at are
generally unaware of how awful they are,
which invites our laughter.
Later on,
Thomas Hobbes modified this a little bit
by saying that laughter was a result of
our competitive nature.
When we laugh,
it's either because we're triumphing
over another or watching their downfall.
Hell,
even take heart,
waded into the discussion calling
laughter.
The result of scorn which proceeds from
are perceiving a small eval and a person
whom we consider to be deserving of it.
In the end,
all three philosophers agree that when
we laugh,
it's at the expense of others to make
ourselves feel good.
While this might seem pretty obvious,
the Big Bang theory isn't Seinfeld.
These aren't horrible people deserving
our scorn.
Case in point,
show runner,
chuck lorre literally said,
the show is not about cakes or nerds,
but about extraordinary people,
so if they're so extraordinary,
why do they deserve to be done?
Which brings us to the big picture
problem.
Instead of building up nerd culture,
the big bang theory kind of tears it
down when the show simply pays lip
service to nerdom mechanically inserting
any reference.
For reference's sake,
the show reveals its contempt for real
nerds.
The details of nerd culture are
irrelevant as long as they sound like
winky assholes.
It's close enough.
I'm attempting to view my work as a
fleeting peripheral image to engage the
superior Colliculus of my brain,
and while the show can fall back on it's
laugh,
track or rip its characters long.
Has he been stuck actually about 30
hours emotionally,
about 29 years.
Ultimately,
this does all of us nerds from the buffy
fan.
So the marvel fans a disservice instead
of finding ourselves reflected on
screen,
we see characters that kind of just get
dumped on.
So what do you think?
Wise crack or we being too harsh on the
biggest show in the world,
or are we being a bunch of jealous
haters,
man,
not that one.
And Hey,
we could have avoided this mess had the
big bang writers know about skillshare,
the online learning community,
whether you're already writing for the
biggest sitcom on CBS or you're just
getting started.
Skill shares got you covered with
classes like powerful storytelling
today,
strategies for crafting great content
out to when the Internet writing for
sketch comedy and even a course about
doodling.
You're way too hilarious ideas.
A premium membership gives you unlimited
access to over 20,000
high quality courses on everything from
design to business to technology.
Millions used skillshare already and
they're giving wisecrack fans two
months.
Greek,
maybe you can send us some Big Bang
theory fanfiction once you've taken a
class or two to sign up.
Go to ski l dot s h slash wise,
crack six to get two months of unlimited
access to over 20,000
classes for free.
Thanks for watching.
And until next time,
peace out.